So now that we have
a functioning Flask application,
let's bring our CRUD
functionality into it.
I will import the code for
SQLAlchemy and
the database engine in sessionmaker
like in Lessons 1 and 2.
Now I'm going to change my
HelloWorld function such that it
performs this following query to grab
the first restaurant out of my database.
And list out all of the menu items and
stored in a string called output.
I'll also add a break line tag to
make my output a bit easier to read.
I will return this output string so
that my user sees it from the browser.
When I save my Python file my flask
server instantly refreshes itself.
So when I refresh the page I now
see all of my menu items listed